we actually found that people who don't
reciprocate these experiments don't
reciprocate at all you get the money
they saved the whole thing so those are
unconditional not reciprocate errs
that's a lot of simples what do we
really call them we call them bastards
my name is Paul's the outcome a
professor of economics at Claremont
Graduate University in Southern
California and direct the Center for
neuro economic studies which is lab that
studies human behaviors in the brain so
new economics we thought of looking at
the brain basis for decision making ah
what does that mean truly about why
people make bad decisions regarding
money so our lab looks at the brain
basis for decision making and those
decisions are very broadly understood
including decisions involving other
people I would ever help someone when
you don't have to why'd you ever be
generous or trustworthy just some of the
issues that we look at that underpin
modern economies so if you think about
how we live as human beings we're
constantly navigating through a sea of
strangers we are not just social
creatures or hyper social creatures most
animals like to be around only their own
offspring only their own family unit or
at most they're kind of small clan based
group we actually like living around
individuals like living in big cities
New York LA so if we're doing that we
must have some mechanism that balances
appropriate levels of trust and distrust
we showed in 2005 that when you receive
money denoting trust your brain releases
a chemical colossi toastin oxytocin
motivates you to reciprocate it makes us
feel empathy for others it connects us
to others and it motivates its
reciprocal behavior currently I call
oxytocin the moral molecule so we found
through 20 or 30 studies we've on the
lab i saw some motivates a variety of
moral behaviour trust within its
generosity compassion forgiveness so it
does that by drawing on this physiology
of love we've shown recently that
physiology of love for offspring bonding
to our mates in a human brain has now
been expanded to include care for
complete strangers so David Hume the
philosopher had this idea of circles of
empathy
talked about having most empathy for
those around us our family our friends
and less for people further away we've
done is that oxytocin in fact has a very
broad circle of empathy certainly we
care about our family and our friends
more than anybody else but this
mechanism is so general purpose and is
so put into high gear and human beings
and in fact we care about complete
strangers now as a kid used to be a lots
of media coverage of some cue to fail
down a well at Texas Willy survives got
a broken leg thought experiment let's
suppose we cap the well the candle stop
crying a little while right so we saved
the two million bucks that will spend
you know going down there building some
apparatus to pull this kid out and we
used to two million bucks and we
vaccinate every child in Mississippi
Louisiana West Virginia will save
hundreds and hundreds of lives why don't
we trade that one life for the two
hundred lives in virginia center we
can't do that right because when we hear
those cries of that child you feel
yourself there we have empathy for that
we can't shut that off so even though
from a sort of pure utilitarian
perspective yes give up one life to save
200 that's much better but it's one
particular life and 200 statistical
lives other lives are not going to see
so the way the brain is set up as social
creatures we can't ignore the police of
that one person this is really
interesting because that in fact is the
basis for trade trade is one person
asking for something another person
giving it to them so in the book i just
finished through more markets we find
that in fact trade depends on morality
because it's that care for the other
it's the same kind of brain mechanism so
mark is depending on morality for three
reasons one humans are inveterate
traders we can't help what we've always
traded you help me I help you you give
me goods I give you money as i said
earlier trade is really an other
regarding behavior depends on virtue
because i have to give you money you
have to give me a good occasionally
there are bad people in the world or
their situations in which would push the
limit and people behave immorally so
just because they're a couple Bernie
menos out there doesn't take away from
the dry cleaner who for free social
buttons on or the clerk at one
who goes to 50 different places help you
find toothbrush those things are
happening all the time and they're part
of our human nature they're part of our
evolved sociality from which trade to
pen so that's number one the second
reason is that there's actually good
evidence now from Aboriginal societies
from small-scale societies that the
extent of trade motivates more behaviors
and laboratory experiments so what trade
tells us that there are win-win
solutions right it's not more for me
less for you most afraid is about you
benefiting and me benefiting I made this
little widget and you're willing to pay
me more than I had to spend to make it
you need the widget I need the money the
more a win it seems like in these
small-scale societies that people have
understood that trade is about a win-win
solution and that's held over and
actually made them in some sense more
moral at least more pro-social in these
experiments involving exchanges of money
the kind of things that we do and
measure oxytocin form so the third
reason is that your brain is very lazy
so i like to say your brains are lazy
republican so it's a Republican because
it's conservative it tries to conserve
energy it has things on autopilot once
you've learned it it becomes a default
pattern it's lazy because it refocuses
it reuses mechanisms the original
develop for one purpose for another
doesn't want to recreate the wheel too
expensive so this lazy Republican brain
it takes that the physiology of care for
offspring the hallmark of mammals using
oxytocin and expands that circle out to
include complete strangers again
modifying or modulating trust and
distrust at appropriate level so once we
learn something this becomes a stanchion
the brain becomes a bias because this
lazy brain doesn't want to rethink oh
here's a new guy what I do so what's my
default behavior if ninety-eight percent
of the individuals are trustworthy which
is exactly what we find our laboratory
experiments ninety-eight percent of
people when you trust em reciprocate
then that's my default I expect people
to reciprocate these two percent is Han
I'm wrong I'm going to be cheated so two
percent about the proportion of
sociopaths in the population but we
actually found that people who don't
reciprocate his experiments don't
reciprocate at all you give them money
they save the whole thing so those are
unconditional not reciprocate errs know
that's a lot of syllables what do we
really call them we call them bastards I
just people you send them money
you know you're giving up money to help
them this money grows and size may keep
the whole thing so these individuals
have a dysregulation in oxytocin they
have very high levels of oxytocin they
don't turn this switch on and off I'm
still since a quick on/off switch these
guys always have this switch stuck we
actually find they have unusual social
behaviors they think deception is okay
they're also self deceptive they don't
really know what they're going to do
themselves kind of in survival mode
because that's how they get through the
world they simulate this behavior so
something hard to identify them so again
the Bernie Madoff not surprising we're
going to have some of those people in
the world this is a good thing Bernie
Madoff is very useful why because it
Tunes our brains and that we're saying
oh well its ninety-eight percent why
shouldn't care you actually need that
small proportion of non reciprocate erza
bastards so that we understand that
these people are in the world moral
markers does not mean all markets at all
times and all people are moral it means
I can design structures that draw on our
innate human nature which is moral at
this moral molecule so that Marcus
depend on morality I think there's a
middle ground and what you understand
the human nature has to make moral sense
and yet Marcus also need the freedom to
evolve and evolution in any sense and
animals and bacteria and markets means
that mistakes will be made and we have
to be comfortable with imperfection so
moral markets mean that by and large if
we allow if we set in place rules that
depend on our own human nature which is
innately moral reciprocal then those
Marcus will flourish because they allow
us to do what we love to do which is
trade with other individuals will the
two percent of bastards appear for sure
and we want to have rules to slam these
people and we do Madoff skilling Kenneth
Lay Ivan Boesky Michael milk and go
through the list why do you remember
them because they're spectacular blobs
and also because they're rare what I
don't know is the name of my dry cleaner
who I picked up my laundry from this
morning I don't know the lady at walmart
who checked me out yesterday because
they did their job right right so I
don't need to know them that's the
beauty of markets everything was well
you can be anonymous I don't need a
top-down designer to tell everyone what
to do we know what
do if i'm doing something wrong i'm
going to know about it pretty soon
because we're social creatures we don't
do things in isolation and again we have
in modern society have mechanisms to
punish those people who go outside the
bounds of what we think is acceptable so
I think this resonates with libertarians
because it says we are not evil as human
beings we actually are having lots of
good at us and there's good and come out
in charitable work in helping our
neighbors and in fact in markets markets
are pro-social markets are about serving
the needs of another right that is
innately virtuous we don't need someone
to tell us to do that it happens very
naturally and yet it takes markets take
this innate moral nature and make it a
win-win solution for everybody